This podcast is brought to you by Worst Bird.
This podcast is brought to you by Worst Bird. Ganz normal und wie immer ist es diese herrliche Stimme, die euch da von hinten schon von der letzten Reihe des Podcast-Business. Stefan. Hallo Stefan. Hallo Florentin, der ist auch normal, sonst ist es nicht so viel normal. Wir sind heute nämlich in Big Apple, wir melden uns aus Big Apple, wir sind nach New York geflogen, um hier zehn Tage lang zu chillen. Ja. Und ja, hier sind wir, wir melden uns da raus, wir sind in so einem kleinen, mitten in Brooklyn in so einem kleinen Räumchen und nehmen hier auf. Ja, wir haben uns versucht, so ein bisschen diese Podcasting-Coolness so ein bisschen mitzunehmen, mal gucken, ob es klappt. Hier haben schon ganz grosse Leute aufgenommen. Wie zum Beispiel Joe Rogan oder andere unabhängige oder dieser der Tiger von Smacks, so solche Leute. Tiger. Tiger, ja. Und ihr hört wahrscheinlich im Hintergrund ein Rauschen, das ist die Klimaanlage, die hier überall standardmäßig in Räumen angebracht wird. Und ich glaube, irgendwann hat man dann so als Amerikaner wie so ein Noise-Canceling-Dingen, dass das rausfiltert, diese Frequenz. Wie ich Autobahnen zum Beispiel nicht mehr höre. Ja, mein Körper ist noch nicht da, irgendwie mitten in der Nacht geht die Klimaanlage an und es ist erst mal Alarm, ich habe schon wirklich die Kinder in der Hand, ich habe irgendwie den Rucksack getankt. Mich in der Hand? Ich habe dir schon Brot geschmiert, ich habe schon den Fluchtplan alles vorbereitet und dann gemerkt, ach nee. Ich habe so eine Rettungsweste an, wo man dann so den Druck ausgleichen kann mit diesem Strohhalm. Ich meine, nee, ist ja nur die Klimaanlage, ist ja gar kein Erdbeben, kein Erdrutsch, keine Erdrisse tun sich auf unter mir, aber da muss der Körper noch hin langsam, dass das geht. Nee, gibt's ja nicht. Wir haben bislang keine Probleme mit Erdbeben. Geht, ist tatsächlich sehr angenehm, muss man sagen. Natürlich Shoutout an Marrakesch, liebe Grüße an Marrakesch. Liebe Grüße. Und ich hoffe, alles ist gut bei euch. Ja, da gab's eben hier im Big Apple nicht so viel. Warum sagt man Big Apple eigentlich? Mag ich nicht. Ich weiss es auch nicht. Ich glaube, einmal im Jahr stellen wir uns diese Frage, warum es The Big Apple ist. Aber es ist natürlich, ich weiss nicht, ob das eine Ansprung auf den Wurm ist. Ich kann ja den Wurm nicht wegdenken bei einem Apple. Du meinst, jetzt ist der Wurm drin. Ich meine, je grösser der Apfel, desto grösser der Wurm. Das weiss ja jeder. Das weiss ich nicht.? Desto mehr Würmer. Ah, okay. Also je ein grosser Apfel viele Würmer, kleiner Apfel wenig Würmer. Das Komische ist ein bisschen, dass wir jetzt an 9-11 hier sind, das muss ich schon mal sagen, das ist ein bisschen merkwürdig. Es hat eine gewisse historische Schwere. Ja. Es liegt so ein bisschen, bei jedem Flugzeug denkt man, aber sie würden das doch nicht nochmal am selben Tag machen, oder? Das ist eine gute Frage, weil eine Freundin fliegt heute am 11. September ebenfalls nach New York und hat gesagt, dass der Flug teurer ist, weil die Versicherung teurer ist. Weil es gibt ja immer bei Flügen eine Versicherung, ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Reines-Ruchtritts-Versicherung ist oder was auch immer, wirklich einfach eine ... Vielleicht ist man versichert, ich weiß es wirklich nicht, jedenfalls ist es teurer, die Flugversicherung
ist teurer am 11. September. Und die Idee ist, dass die Terroristen
sich da nicht das Ticket leisten können und sagen, ach,
verdammt nochmal, dann machen wir
was von anders. Ja, oder
dass sie davon, also ich finde auch die
Vorstellung interessant, dass es einfach, also
Versicherungen sagen, der Termin ist
wahrscheinlicher für weitere Terroranschläge,
und da würde ich nicht mitgehen.
Andererseits ist es wie bei Roulette, man ist da auch dumm. Wenn die 36 gerade kam, nimmst du danach nicht die 36, weil du denkst, ah, jetzt ist die wahrscheinlich nicht dran, aber die wahrscheinlich ist trotzdem genauso groß. Es gibt ja auch so eine Peinlichkeitsversicherung generell im Leben. Du kannst ja nicht, wenn du am 11. September schon mal so was hattest, kannst ja nicht noch mal am selben Tag passieren. Das ist wie wenn du ja irgendwo zu einer Party gehst und jemand schreibt dir vergiss nicht den Kartoffelsalat. Und dann denkst du, ich hätte ihn nicht vergessen. Aber jetzt kann ich ihn auf gar keinen Fall vergessen. So. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich ihn heute jetzt vergesse... Aber jetzt denkt die Person, dass du den nur mitgebracht hast, weil sie sich erinnert hat. Ich hätte daran gedacht. Ja, aber jetzt kannst du es nicht mehr vergessen. Denkst du anoffersal mitnehmen. Denkst du an die Brötchen noch später, Schatz?
Ja, hätte ich auch getan.
Ja, glaube ich nicht.
Ja, aber woher willst du es wissen, wenn du es jedes Mal sagst?
Weil du die oft vergisst.
Gott.
Nee, aber das stimmt, ne?
Also man kann es dann nicht mehr beweisen.
Es ist dann allein die Peinlichkeit.
Ich habe auch mal, irgendjemand hat uns mal, als wir lange überlegt haben, ob wir eine
Bank ausrauben sollen, um wir beiden so ein bisschen unseren Haushalt auch zu bessern, wir haben uns letzten Endes dann dagegen entschieden. Hä, aber wir haben uns doch dafür entschieden. Stefan. Hä, warum sollst du mich an? Wir haben uns doch dafür entschieden. Deswegen habe ich mich für eine andere Crew entschieden und habe Stefan so ein bisschen rausgenommen aus der Planungsphase. Ist aber jetzt ein ganz anderes Thema. Und da sind wir in der Recherche auch auf einen Fall gestossen, dass irgendwo eine Bank überfallen wurde. Und nächstes Jahr wurde sie am gleichen Tag nochmal überfallen, am gleichen Tag. Und das Jahr darauf nochmal am gleichen Tag. Danach wurde die Filiale geschlossen. Weil man gesagt hat, das ist zu peinlich. Icke, das wird ja eigentlich komplett bescheuert. Das ist zu peinlich. Die ganze Belegschaft saß so mit gesenktem Haupt und der Herr Sparkasse, der Sparfuchs kam dann an. Herr Vorsitzender der Sparkasse. Ja. Der Vereinigten Sparkasse. Sammer, breit euch der Hut! Sir, Sir, Vorsitzender aller Sparkassen und der Vereinigten Sparkassen. Ich bin Stocksauer! Ich weiß. Das könnt ihr doch nicht machen, dreimal in Folge. Aber Sie müssen doch verstehen, beim ersten Mal, ne, kann ja immer passieren, Banken werden immer überfallen, ständig überfallen, so, das kann ja passieren. Im zweiten Jahr sind wir einfach davon ausgegangen, dass, wir waren an jedem Tag gut vorbereitet, an diesem konkreten Tag haben wir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen freigemacht und gefeiert, weil wir dachten, es wird ja wohl nicht an diesem Tag nochmal passieren.
Im dritten Jahr, als es dann zweimal am gleichen Tag passiert ist, dachten wir, waren wir uns hundertprozentig sicher, dass es nicht wieder an dem gleichen Tag passieren wird. Und dann habt ihr extra den Tresor aufgemacht? Man kann ihn nicht so häufig aber aufmachen. Es ist auch befriedigend, dieses Riesenrad. Das war einer der wenigen Fehler meiner Karriere, diese Räder so riesig und befriedigend gemacht zu haben. Diese grossen Tresorräder. Das müsste eigentlich eher so ein riesiger Klettverschluss sein, wo so fünf Leute gleichzeitig und dann weg, oh nee, nicht nochmal in den Tresor. Wir haben Angst, diese Geräusche. Diese Geräusche haben Angst. Und das ist die eigentliche Alarmanlage. Du hörst nur, und dann kannst du die Sonaranlagen überall machen, und dann hörst du, wann der Klettverschluss aufgeht. Weil ich glaube, du kannst einen Klettverschluss unmöglich leise aufmachen. Du glaubst, man kann einen Klettverschluss unmöglich leise aufmachen. Ich glaube, die Langsamkeit. Ich glaube, die langsamer du einen Klettverschluss aufmachst, als du leiser esst. Weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, du hörst es noch was. Das wäre mal so ein Uri Geller-Move, da würde ich sagen, wow. Hier sind so viele Geräusche in diesem Horrorhaus. Ihr müsst euch das vorstellen, wir sind wie in so einem Bienenstock, wo wirklich 16, wir sind ein großes Hochhaus und auf jede Etage sind 20 Podcasting-Studios. Da hinten ging es ja noch weiter. Ich war doch im Kloflotting nicht.. Ich habe mir erzählt, da hinten geht noch ein Flur weiter. Und überall sind so diese Aluminium-Tür neben Aluminium-Tür. Alles sind Podcast-Studios. Ich glaube, hier sind bestimmt 1800 Podcast-Studios. Ich glaube, ein Grossteil aller Podcasts der Welt entstehen hier. Wirklich. Und alle Räume sehen exakt gleich aus. Das finde ich auch lustig. Und alle exakt so aussehen wie hier im Hintergrund. Komische Bilder stehen hier, eine Figur mit so Maßbändern, wir sind nicht ganz klar, wo wir hier sind. Ja, man kann das hier für Mode nutzen und Fotoshootings, wir sind auf jeden Fall gut aufgestellt, werden noch ein paar heisse Pics shooten. Stefan, weil du ja meintest, du willst so ein bisschen in die Aktfotografie, bist du jetzt bereit, wo du sagst, jetzt bist du mit deinem Körper im Reinen und kannst dich jetzt ablichten lassen? Weil ab dem gewissen Punkt wird es ja auch nicht mehr besser. Nee, meine Idee war ja mal, so lange Sport zu machen, bis man irgendwann einmal eine Traumfigur hat, dann ein Bild bei Instagram postet, wie wenn diese Traumfigur hat und dann alles wieder vernachlässigt und den Bach runtergehen lässt. Und die Idee ist, dass du dann immer schlecht aussiehst im Vergleich, oder was? Nee, ich dachte eher, niemand naja, du hast schon recht, die Enttäuschung ist dann gross. Eigentlich musst du es anders machen, du musst dich einmal richtig komplett gehen lassen, dann Bild und dann kannst du wieder normal leben, sozusagen, dass du im Vergleich immer gut aussiehst. Ich interpretiere Instagram eher als grosse Bewerbung. Bewerbung an die Welt. Genau, und dann ist es fast egal, was danach dann in echt passiert. Ja, wir melden uns, würde ich sagen, sagt die Welt. Ja, vielen Dank, dass Sie da waren und wir würden uns dann melden, wenn wir Sie brauchen. Ansonsten danke, dass Sie die Fahrt gemacht haben.
Ja, sterbe ich jetzt.
Wenn ich bei der Wiedervorlage auf der Welt bin. Wie gesagt, wir melden uns.
Wir würden uns melden.
Danke.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wohin.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich rauskommen soll.
Einmal die Tür hier, bitte.
Es sind tausend Türen. Welche Tür?
Die da. Die zweite.
Die teigen Waage in eine Richtung.
Die zweite. Ungefähr so. Ja, dann gehe ich dann da durch jetzt. Tschüss. Tot? Tot? Hast du einen Moment? Ja, sicherlich. Habe ich einen kleinen Moment. Pass mal auf. Ja. Schnapp dir den mal. Der ist ... Den Kerl, der in der Tür steht. Mockler. Hol ich mir doch kurz. Hast du Zeit heute noch? Ja, klar. Ja, wunderbar. Danke dir, ne. Danke, dass du immer... Ja, na klar. Und deswegen, weißt du, du redest respektvoll mit mir. Und deswegen mag ich dich. Aber das ist nett von dir, klar. Wir arbeiten gut zusammen. Die Welt und der Tod? Naja. Was ist die Moral von diesem Skit? Naja, das werden wahrscheinlich Schülerinnen und Schüler in 20 Jahren im Deutsch-LK nochmal genau auseinanderdröseln und sich gefragt haben, was soll das heißen. Apropos schwierige Interpretationen, wir waren ja vor New York noch in London und da war ich natürlich als großer Fan im Globe Theater. Globe Shakespeare! Shakespeare das Globe Theater! Florentin hat sich im Viertel nur Shakespeare gegeben. Schöne Sonne auf die Stirn im Globe Theater. Es ist wirklich so ein kompletter Nachbau des ursprünglichen Globe Theaters, das damals einmal komplett abgebrannt war. Also es ist komplett abgebrannt, dieses hölzerne Heudach-Theater. Das ursprüngliche bei Shakespeare, das war so ein bisschen die Idee Shakespeare, der war am Anfang ja irgendwie so arm und dann hat er irgendwie immer mehr Geld und immer beliebter. Und dann eines Tages hat er gesagt, Leute, ich baue euch jetzt ein Theater, wie es sein muss. So stelle ich mir das vor, so muss das Theater sein. Und dann ist dieses Globe Theater entstanden und dann ist aber abgebrannt, weil während einer Inszenierung eine Kanone abgefeuert wurde und das Heudach in Brand gesetzt wurde. Und man gesagt hat, puh, schade, es gehört nicht zur Inszenierung. Also Heubrennen ist gewaltig gut, hat man dann gedacht. Genau. Und diese Sprinkleranlagen, die damals noch manuell waren, wo so Leute oben mit so Wasserflaschen... Wo so Leute so durch die Zähne... Ja. Die Feuerwehr damals in London. Hat nicht funktioniert. Die stand aus Leuten, die... Und dann so durch die Zähne... Musst dich zum Lachen bringenils genau, ja, spit take was nicht einfach ist, wenn Brand entsteht und Leute sterben wenn deine Heusandalen und deine Heuhose alle in Brand stehen und dann wurde es wieder aufgebaut, wieder mit einem Heudach also es war kein es gab keinen Lerneffekt meine Frage, jetzt hat man das Holz legiert das weiß ich nicht ehrlich gesagt und ich habe während der Inszenierung so geguckt und es hatte immer noch ein Heudach, weil das wurde dann irgendwann geschlossen, weil irgendwann wurde Theater verboten auch und dann hat niemand mehr dieses Theater gebraucht. Weswegen? Zu schlecht? Weil sollte man mal das Fernsehen verbieten? Ja, ne, weil die Puritaner tatsächlich, Puritans, haben gesagt, nee, das funktioniert so nicht, da gehen nur die Asozialen hin und die von niedrigem Stand gehen da hin und da
die machen sich lustig, überadlige und so
Kram. Genau bin ich da nicht drin, aber so ungefähr.
Klingt, als wärst du sehr tief drin.
Dann haben die das geschlossen. Klingt, als wärst du das Fenster, ist auch gut.
Und dann waren, naja,
ich sag mal, da waren schon auch Asoziale
in Theater. Egal.
Und dann haben die es stehen gelassen,
da waren Wohnhäuser drin,
was ich auch geil fand, dass dann Leute auf der Bühne
gewohnt haben oder in den Logen
Und dann, wenn wir uns das,, da waren Wohnhäuser drin. In dem Theater. Was ich auch geil fand, dass dann Leute auf der Bühne gewohnt haben oder in den Logen. Und irgendwann haben sie gesagt, komm, das reissen wir ab für echte Wohnhäuser. Und jetzt hat irgendjemand 2006 oder so gesagt, komm, wir bauen das alles wieder auf. Ja. Und jetzt steht das Globe Theater wieder in London, ganz grandios. Und da habe ich eine Inszenierung gesehen von As You Like It. As You Like It. As You Like It. As You Like It. Und das war auch grossartig, weil das Stück selber hat auch so eine ... War das grossartig? Es hat schon grossen Spaß gemacht. Und das hatte auch so eine Inszenierung, weil das Stück selber ist so ein bisschen mit Metaperspektive und spielt so ein bisschen mit den Erwartungen an, wie eine Liebesgeschichte sein hat und so und blablabla. So eine Zeitreisegeschichte, es ist Shakespeare's Zeitreisegeschichte. Genau. Also viele, die die Story jetzt nicht kennen, es geht um Cedric, Cedric reist in die Vergangenheit, um Baby Hitler zu töten. Genau. Und dann gibt es auch diese Zombie, diesen Zombie-Epilog. Genau, und dann ist immer eine Figur, die immer so Augen zwinkert, dann so, ah, was wir hier sehen und so. Und die sagt dann immer, oh well, I guess that just happened. Ja. Ja,
that just has happened.
Und dann gibt's,
die Idee ist, eine Figur
verkleidet sich als Mann und muss dann als Mann
irgendwie rum. Also sehr viel mit
auch Geschlechterrollen
und Geschlechterstereotypen wird gespielt und so.
Und da gibt's eine Szene,
wo die Figur dann als Mann
verkleidet sagt, she's a woman and as a woman everything she thinks she says.
Und dann hat die Schauspielerin aber mit der Hand so eine, naja, Geste gemacht, also um allen zu zeigen, das steht so im Stück, aber es ist so ein bisschen, was ich ganz interessant fand, was ich ganz charmant fand eigentlich, dass man so den alten Text inszeniert, aber mit so einer Distanzierung zu sagen, so, und das Publikum fand es mega. Ja, vor allem. Wir können überall lachen, dass es ein bisschen natürlich sechs oder vierhundert Jahre alt ist. Was du sagst, ist ja auch nicht, was du meinst. Aber es passt total gut zu dem Stück. Ich finde es völlig legitim, quasi, er hat ja nur das Drehbuch verfasst, also das Playwright in dem Fall. Und da kannst du ja damit machen, was du willst. Und was man sagt, ist ja nicht unbedingt, was man meint. Und auch wenn er so geschrieben hat, dass die Figur das sehr wohl meint, was sie sagt, kann man ja mit einer guten Inszenierung auch dagegen arbeiten. Nee, darum ging es mir gar nicht Shakespeare gut oder schlecht, sondern ich fand es einfach interessant, dass die in dieser MetDiskussion da noch so ein... Aber jetzt war es die Shakespeare gut oder schlecht? Mir hat es sehr gut gefallen, doch hat halt großen Spaß gemacht, muss ich schon sagen. Sehr cool. Ja, war ich leider nicht. Ich war währenddessen damit mit einer Weinflasche im Park gelegen. Vielleicht das echte Künstlerleben gelebt, aber es ist so ein charmantes Projekt, weil da auch lauter Rentner sind, die da halt freiwillig helfen. Weil das ist halt, also man muss schon zahlen, aber es ist jetzt kein so ein großes Profitprojekt. Und halt so die ganzen Ordner und so sind alles Rentner. Und dann steht auch immer freiwilliger Helfer so. Will man auch nicht hinten drauf stehen haben. Und die sind dann immer freiwillig, die haben auch strenge Regeln, gefällt mir sehr, sehr gut tatsächlich, muss ich sagen. Strenge Regeln, man darf nicht filmen, man darf sich nur da hinsitzen, wo man sitzen darf, und vorne gibt's so einen grossen Bereich, wo man nur stehen darf, und dann wird man sofort ermahnt, wenn man sich irgendwo hinsetzt und so, und fand ich toll, dass du da so eine Herrscher Rentner hast, die einfach da nochmal schön pedantisch alle zurechtweisen können. Ich hab mir überlegt, dir ein Shirt zu kaufen, wo hinten einfach nur Staff draufsteht. Generell können wir uns auch mal überlegen, ob wir das nicht im Podcast-Sufo-Merch-Shop anbieten. Einfach ein schwarzes Shirt und hinten draufsteht mit so Areal in all caps S-T-A-F-F Staff. Finde ich total... Du kannst überall rein, kannst überall mitmachen. Ja, finde ich absolut super. Du kannst überall rein. Alle fragen sich, wovon ist er Staff? Genau, man weiß ja nicht, weil der Staff-Mitarbeiter muss ja auch zur Arbeit fahren und wenn er in der U-Bahn ist, ist er dann schon Staff oder nicht? Also wenn im Wald ein Staff-T-Shirt Forstamt. Ist es dann Teil des Waldes oder nicht? Oder wo ist es, gehört es hin? Wenn du in der U-Bahn zur Arbeit fährst, denken alle an Uber- U-Bahn-Mitarbeiter. Ah, der ist bei der KVB, BVG, HVV, name it, you name it. Ihr kennt die ganzen Strecken. HVB, KVV und MFG. Nee, das stimmt. Ich finde es eine gute Idee, eigentlich sind Staffschule. Ich glaube, das ist wie diese Weste oder eine Leitertragen befähigt dich zu sehr viel. Ja, oder das Klemmbrett. Klemmbrett, das war ein rücktes Klemmbrett. Einfach Leute zurechtweisen,weisen, ja. Wir fahren jetzt vier U-Bahnen hier in New York. Du wolltest auch was sagen, was dich groß erinnert. Ich wollte nur sagen, dass ich ja auch mal als Ordner gearbeitet habe, aber allerdings im LMU Raumcontrolling. Im was, was, was? Im LMU Raumcontrolling. Im LMU Raumcontrolling, du kannst nicht sagen, als wäre das der extremste Job. Die Ludwig-Maximilians-Universität München Raumcontrolling, da war ich unterwegs und kam zu spät zur Einweisung, weswegen für mich nur noch ein XXL-T-Shirt übrig war. Und dann hatte ich so ein Raumcontrolling-T-Shirt, das mir viel zu gross war. Und ich glaube, ich war die einzige technisch gesehen Staffperson, die weniger Autorität genossen hat als der Durchschnittsbürger. Ich war wie so ein Ge. Untergräbt die Botschaft auch deinen Job, also Raumcontrolling, aber dann hast du so einen riesen Shirt an, was so aussieht, als ob du deinen Raum nicht gut kontrollierst. Genau, ja. Untergräbt die Botschaft deines Jobs. Ja, im Grunde schon. Ich habe meinen eigenen Raum nicht unter Kontrolle. Deswegen haben die meisten Dozenten auch gesagt, bring erstmal deinen eigenen Raum unter Kontrolle, bevor du hier versuchst, unsere Räume zu kontrollieren. Es ist wie so ein Fashion-Staff, Fashion-Team-Mitarbeiter, der halt keinen, der einfach eine Jeans trägt und... Wir sind hier übrigens auch gerade während der Fashion Week, haben wir gerade erfahren. Also wir können hier noch ein bisschen die Laufstärke ruhiger machen. Ja, passen hier einfach rein. Also mich kann man, erkennt man mich ja nicht als Fremdkörper. Ja, klar, ich liebe Fashion, Fashion ist mein Leben, ich kann mich dadurch ausdrücken. Und gerade ist Fashion ist einfach meine Welt. Kommt aber wieder diese 90er Jahre Bad-Taste-Sachen. Bad-Taste? Inwiefern meinst du, warum meinst du Bad-Taste? Nee, diese Bad-Taste-Shirts, so Simpsons oder Gracie Films. Aber das ist ja, warum Bad-Taste ist ja wirklich modisch und zeitlos. Das kommt ja wieder jetzt. Das kommt ja wieder, das ist ja genau, will man ja. Das heißt, ab einem gewissen Punkt trägt man es einfach weiter, aber ironisch dann. Nee, nicht ironisch, ich glaube, völlig ernst trägt man gerade Bad-Taste-Sachen. Okay, du sagst immer wieder Bad-Taste, wenn du über meine Kleidung redest. Nee, ich meine nicht deine Kleidung, ich meine generell trägt man ja gerade so 90er Jahre, so verwaschene 90er Jahre, schallt es wieder auf. Du hast übrigens gesagt ...
Und deswegen, das mag ich nicht an Mode,
dass Mode primär ein Mittel ist, um Leute zu demütigen.
Deswegen habe ich mich relativ früh in meiner Jugend
schon von Mode verabschiedet.
Ich verstehe das.
Weil es immer hiess, ja, warum hast du eine kurze Hose an,
warum hast du das falsch an.
Immer auch Abgrenzung, Ausgrenzung.
Und ich dachte mir, lass es, lass mich in Ruhe.
Ich lebe in der Cyberwelt, mein Avatar hat Hose plus drei Stärke, darauf kommt's an. Ich mag's aber auch als Mittel, um sich selber auszudrücken. Daran unterscheiden wir uns, glaube ich, ein bisschen. Es ist nicht nur ... Was drückst du gerade aus mit deinem schwarzen T-Shirt? Ich hab das angezogen, weil du gesagt hast, beim 9-11-Memorial muss ich ... Man kann nicht ... Es sind draußen 35 Grad, und ich trage eine lange Hose und dieses schwarze Shirt, weil du meintest, nicht pietätlos anziehen. Ja, wir waren am 9-11 Memorial, da kannst du nicht mit deiner Snoopy-kurzen Hose ankommen und irgendwie dein Feinripp-T-Shirt, das geht nicht. Da musst du schon was tragen. Ich habe auch extra mein Gracie-Films-T-Shirt angezogen und eine lange Jogginghose. Gut, ich habe Sandalen an, aber Sandalen sind ja nicht notwendigerweise... Pietätlos. Nicht Pietätlos. Findest du Pietätlos? Nee, nicht unbedingt Pietätlos. Ich wollte deinen Satz vervollständigen. Ich wollte nicht einen eigenen Punkt machen. Je tiefer am Körper, desto egaler das Kleidungs. Gerade, also damit sage ich jetzt nicht so viel aus. Geht, ist ein Basic-Shirt. Ein schwarzes Basic-Shirt kann man immer machen. Okay, das ist dein Ausdruck. Naja, cool. Minimalistisch. Steve Jobs hat sich auch gut ausgedrückt durch seine Kleidung. Und die war sehr minimalistisch. Ja, okay, gut, aber Steve Jobs hat nebenbei auch noch iPhones gebaut und Krebs gehabt. Krebs gehabt? Naja, also... Du weißt ja nicht, was ich habe. Okay. Naja, jedenfalls fahren wir gerade im Flugzeug, war es auch ... Keiner der viel über die U-Bahn. Jetzt sind immer so die ... Ich lieb die U-Bahn. Die kleinen Essenzahnen. Und ich hab gemerkt, das ist sehr lustig, dass du als Deutscher, zumindest ich, starre die Leute down. Ja? Ich starre. Du starst die Leute an an in der U-Bahn? Ja, und alle hängen am Handy und gucken so super down und miserable auf ihre Handys. Und ich gucke die an. Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass das glaube ich nicht so gut ankommt, relativ schnell. Am ersten Tag bereits hier. Ich muss aber auch sagen, mir macht das auch Spaß so, die Menschen gucken und interessant, weil die sind alle,
die New Yorker U-Bahn ist wirklich einfach
wie so ein Schlachtfeld, wo
jeder einfach Kopf nach unten,
einfach wird nicht getroffen von irgendwelchen
Leuten. Bei mir hat einfach einer mitten
im Zug angefangen, irgendein Lied zu
singen, irgend so ein religiöses
Ritual-Chorallied,
irgend so hinduistisches irgendwas,
einfach
Maria. Ah, so ein Sektenlied. Und hättest du nur Bild gehabt, hättest du es nicht gemerkt, weil niemand hat aufgeguckt, niemand alle weiter, einfach weiter in ihre Welt, in ihrem Sog, einfach nur, lass dich nicht ausrauben, nur nicht ausgeräumt werden. Ja, um ein Klischees zu besprechen und alles zu vereinfachen, zu pauschalisieren. Der Amerikaner ist ja gut im Smalltalk, der Deutsche ja nicht, der Amerikaner guckt aber in der Bahn auf den Boden und der Deutsche guckt die Leuten ins Gesicht.
Ja, ja. Und da habe ich gemerkt, das ist gerade unüblich.
Völlig vereinfacht, stimmt auch nicht, viele gucken auch rum, die meisten haben aber in
der New Yorker U-Bahn Handys in der Hand, tippen darauf rum, sind darin, in ihrer Welt versunken,
schade, Fragezeichen, what has become of us? Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir, ist ja auch, mache ich ja auch, zu Hause in der U-Bahn, in New York finde ich es so spannend zu gucken, nicht nur, was tragen die Leute, wie sehen die hier alle aus, was ist der neue heiße Scheiss, was trägt man jetzt? Ich gucke mir, andere Leute andere mir herausfinden, wie ich mich dann klein und technisch selbst erwirklichen will. Ah, okay. Und dann guckt man auch oben, was steht da oben an Werbung oder sowas und das finde ich schon cool. Deswegen guckt man, glaube ich, auch hier anders, als wenn man hier wohnen würde, als Stadtfremder, Fremde dann schon einfach rum. Ja, absolut. Es ist alles interessant irgendwie. Jede Mülltonne denkt man sich, wie so ein Star, du warst in einem New Yorker Film. Ich finde es so lustig, weil man sagt ja manchmal, wenn man in der Stadt ist, ah, die Menschen sind hier so schön oder so, keine Ahnung. Man geht in eine Stadt oder so, dann ist es auch dieser Urlaubseffekt oder man ist selber gut gelaunt oder keiner, aber man hat dann dieses, hört man ab und zu mal, die Menschen sind hier schön. Und hier finde ich es so spannend, weil es manchmal für mich gar nicht ist wie die sind so anders angezogen oder so modisch advanced in anderen Sphären, die ich gar nicht verstehe, das kann ich gar nicht beurteilen. Es ist wie eine andere Spezies. Es ist wie Homo sapiens fashionista und da kann ich dann fast nicht mehr mit. Ich kann das gar nicht beurteilen. Sehen die jetzt, ist das jetzt gut, ist das jetzt schlecht, ich hab keine Meinung dazu. So wie man jetzt Tiere attraktiv findet. Auch ganz merklich, auch unhandlich. Ich war in Manhattan unterwegs und dann kam mir so eine Frau entgegen, die anscheinend sehr modisch angezogen war. Und ihre Hose war ungefähr doppelt so lang wie ihr Bein. Einfach so. Die Hose war viel zu lang. Das heißt, sie lief in ihrer Hose auf dem Boden. Sie lief in ihrer Hose und hat so die Hälfte des Hosenbeins hinterhergezogen.
Und die hatte wirklich einfach Probleme, voranzukommen.
Aber ihr ganzer Look und alles...
Siehst du, und da sagt mir mein Körper... Hose und hat so die Hälfte des Hosenbeins hinterhergezogen und die hatte wirklich einfach Probleme, voranzukommen. Aber ihr ganzer Look und alles wirkte einfach so, als wäre das ihr Style. Obwohl ich mir wirklich dachte so, ich meine, cool, viel Spaß, vielleicht ist das für irgendeine Art von Stelzenlaufweg gedacht oder was, vielleicht ist die Stelzenmodel, keine Ahnung, für die neue Stelzenshow, ich weiss ja nicht, was hier so gerade der Hype ist,
vielleicht setzen die Stelzen endlich durch,
aber das war auf jeden Fall
interessant, wo ich mir wirklich dachte, da steht Mode einfach
im Weg, das ist wie so ein Pfau, der diese
riesigen Federn hat und immer so
an jedem Strauch eng bleibt und so
durch jede Ecke, ja genau,
Scheiss Bullshit immer hier,
zieht den halben Beide, das ist aber auch eng,
scheiss Dreck hier mal, ah ne wenn ein Pfau hat einen schlechten Tag.
Einfach so komplett, er kriegt das ja auch dann immer nicht raus, da hängen dann irgendwelche Äste in den Fehlern.
Findest du ein Pfau heiß?
Schon.
Aber ich, okay, Topfen, hotteste Tiere.
Ich finde ein Pfau heiß, aber ich wüsste nicht, was ich mit ihm tun soll.
Also wenn er mich, wenn er mich zu sich nach Hause bittet, ich wäre dabei, aber ich glaube, ich wüsste dann nicht genau, wohin rumknutschen könntest du ja. Ah, weiss ich nicht, mit einem Schnabel? Mit einem Schnabel? Ja, wie da la la la la, du kannst an einem Schnabel rutschen. Aber Knutschen funktioniert ja nur, weil Lippen beweglich sind und weich. Zwei, also Vögel.
Vögel haben ich schon oft.
Meine Wäldensäte damals, ich glaube, die haben sich gegenseitig Essen in den Mund.
Das würde ich jetzt auch nicht als Küssen oder Knutschen bezeichnen.
Ne, Würgen.
Ja, okay, gut.
Aber das geht ja auch, sie können ja ihre Schnäbel verkeilen.
Ich will nur von dir wissen, was sind die hottesten Tiere?
Oh, gute Frage. Ich habe das gestern schon mal zu dir gesagt, full disclosure, weil ich finde das schon, man hat nämlich eine Meinung zu Tieren. Und ich finde das interessant, weil man hat ja gar keine sexuellen oder so Beziehungen zu Tieren. Es gibt wahrscheinlich Menschen, die das haben, Zophilie oder whatever, aber ja viele nicht. Und trotzdem hat man ja eine Meinung zu, ah, das ist ein ekliges Tier und es gibt Tiere, die ich nicht von der Bettgarde stoff. Ja, auf jeden Fall, ja, ja, klar. Ich meine, wenn du so ein Löwe mit so einer Mähne und so wirklich diese Narben im Gesicht zu dieser, ich meine, man macht ja, macht man ja, wenn man flirtet, also die Tigerklaue, ist ja der quintessentielle sexy Tier, ist ja der Tiger, warum? Hi. Wohingegen so eine so eine Legehenne, ja, wenig treu, aber kein Abenteuer. Nee, genau. Panther, finde ich wieder. Ich bin in dieser Ecke. Aber ich glaube deswegen, man sagt ja auch Catwalk. Ich glaube, so diese klassische Mode-Hüftbewegung ist ja ähnlich wie bei Katzen. Also ich glaube, das kann vielleicht einfach ein biologischer Zufall sein, dass die ähnlich laufen wie wie sage ich mal hüftbetonter Gang bei Menschen.
Vielleicht ist es einfach nur Zufall, weswegen wir
einfach Wildkatzen einfach extrem
heiß finden und uns in ihren
Farben auch fleiten.
Das kann schon sein.
Die sind so, oh Gott, Wildkatzen.
Nee, aber
das finde ich schon, ich finde es interessant.
Ich glaube, eine gewisse Geschmeidigkeit ist schon wichtig.
Also zum Beispiel ein Pinguin, der sehr unflexibel ist. Ungelenk. Ungelenk eine Röhre einfach. Clumsy. Da, weiss ich nicht. Ja, das stimmt, ne, also, finde ich schon interessant. Ich habe mir einen Stuhl nach unten bewegt. Wann hört das auf, wann komme ich in ein Alter, wo das nicht mehr cool oder lustig ist? Das bleibt immer cool.
Das bleibt immer cool.
Bin ein bisschen zu niedrig.
Das musst du einfach nur dramaturgisch auch immer richtig timen.
Wenn wir gesagt haben, ja, Herr Tietze, Sie sind gefeuert.
Und dann einfach einmal zehn Zentimeter nach unten.
Was?
Ach, du meinst als Reaktion darauf?
Ja, als Reaktion. Als Enttäuschung.
Du musst immer wirklich, immer schön Hand am Griff und im richtigen Moment musst du zugreifen.
Du musst immer wissen, wann es losgeht.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Ihr Fortschritt, der sich in der Welt befindet, ist, dass die Welt der Welt? Ja, als Reaktion musst du immer, du musst immer wirklich, immer schön Hand am Griff und im richtigen Moment musst du zugreifen, musst du immer wissen, wann es losgeht. Das ist ganz wichtig. Ja, vor allem, wenn jemand irgendwie eine Obrigkeit oder sowas ausdrücken will. Angenommen, ich fühle jetzt ein unangenehmes Gespräch mit dir, meine Mitarbeiter, als Chef. Und man macht dann halt diese Geste. Ja, okay, Co, Co. Man macht diese Geste so und dann macht man den Stuhl hoch. Das ist so unangenehm. Weil man sieht ja, dass es gerade synthetisch die fehlende Augenhöhe quasi heraufbeschworen hat, indem er das selber hoch macht. Das machen Leute. Das ist auch so ein Ärztemove. Oder Ärzte haben auch oft, finde ich, so einen Hohn und dann pumpen die sich teilweise so runter auf deine Ebene oder hoch und du sitzt auf dem Ding und denkst, ich habe keine Möglichkeit der Höhenveränderung. Ich würde gern mitpumpen. Wenn der hoch pumpt, will ich auch hoch pumpen. Ich will auf Augenhöhe bleiben, aber es geht nicht. Du hast einfach nur eine Möglichkeit. Manche Menschen machen sich dann hoch bei diesen Pumpstühlen und ich finde es so albern, weil man sieht das doch. Ihr müsst nicht so hoch sein. Ihr wollt gerade irgendwie komisch zeigen, dass ihr über mir steht oder sowas. Das ist wirklich albern. Das ist wirklich albern. Aber ich bin immer noch in dem Alter, dass ich mich sehr freue über Pumpstühle. Sorry, ich wollte nicht dein Bild untergraben. Ich meine, auch Drehstühle oder sowas sind fantastisch. Habe ich immer wieder Spaß daran, einfach schön den Reindreher oder den Rausdreher oder einfach mitten im Gespräch zwischen zwei Sätzen einfach, ich glaube, wir müssen uns von ihm verabschieden. Hattest du nicht mal in deinem Kinderzimmer so eine Drehschaukel? Ich hatte eine Ein-Mann-Hängematte. Also die klassische Ey, setz dich mit mir in die Hängematte, hatte ich alleine, Single. Setz dich mit mir in die Ein-Mann-Hängematte. Und dann konntest du halt, du hängst halt in der Luft, dann habe ich Fernsehen geschaut und die hat sich dann so langsam zur Seite gedreht und ich musste immer so dagegen rudern so ein bisschen. Was aber auch ein Workout gemacht hat, was dazu geführt hat, dass ich heute sehr kräftige Handgelenke habe. Ja, das sieht man, das sind riesige Handgelenke. Diese starke Handgelenke, wie packe ich alles an. Wie so ein Panther. Wenn ich mich schön irgendwie im Auto festhalte oder so, Stahlgriff. Ach so, oben das Ding in der Hand dann plötzlich. Ja, ich, also, ja, ich genieße die Zeit hier sehr, ich bin sehr froh, dass wir hier sind. Es ist sehr schön, auch wenn es natürlich immer schwierig ist und ich schon viele Fehler gemacht habe und man ja immer denkt, wenn man hierher kommt, so, naja, Englisch-Leistungskurs und so und naja, ich schaue ja irgendwie auch hier Sopranos im Original. Ja, okay. Und dann kommst du hier an und dann Sarah mal. Was ich beobachte, ist immer Florentin Hm? Oder Excuse me? Es ist immer, man versteht nicht, dann doch nicht so viel. Vor allem, ich würde behaupten, dass wir sehr gut Englisch verstehen können, also auf so einem, weil wir so viel Kram gucken. Aber es ist oft auch ein akustisches Ding, weil es einfach eine extrem laute Stadt ist. Es ist einfach Excuse me? Sorry? Und dann anderen Flugzeuge, die in ein Gebäude reinfliegen. Es ist auch laut. Aber irgendwo denke ich mir auch, sorry. Nein, nennst du es. Aber manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, das ist nicht meine Schuld, weil ich hatte gestern einen harten Tag und ... Hey, hast du ja gar nicht mehr erzählt, als wir abends noch im Wohnzimmer ein bisschen den Abend besprochen haben und haben, als du mit so einem Budweiser nochmal schön einen Zischen gelassen hast und nicht mir vier Twinkies reingeschoben hast. Das sagt man nicht, einen Zischen gelassen haben. Das Ding hat nicht gefurzt. Was sagst du, ich habe mir einen Zischen gelassen. Einen gezischt zum Beispiel, aber er hat einen Zischen gelassen, das sagt man nicht beim Bier. Wenn ich mit meinen Jungs mir einen Zischen gelassen habe, glaube ich, ist es kein Problem. Ronny, Rudow und ich sitzen da und gönnen uns ordentlich einen frischen. Das sagt man nicht. Klar, wir frischen uns einen Zapfen rein. Ihr habt euch einen gezischt. Wir zapschen uns einen frischen rein. Ja, okay, meinetwegen. Aber sag nicht einen Zwischen gelassen haben. Ich wollte gestern zum legendären Katz Delikatessen. Das ist ein ganz legendärer Sandwich-Laden hier in New York, wo es ganz dicke Sandwiches gibt, berühmt natürlich durch Harry, Matt Sally, die berühmte Szene, viele, viele andere kulturelle Referenzen sind angehängt im Register. Blättert gerne nach. Schaut mal in den Shownotes. Wir haben gemerkt, dass die Fussnoten sehr wenig frequentiert werden. Es gibt die Shownotes und Florentin hat ja auch immer noch ein bisschen Zeit, ne, und eh nicht so viel zu tun, und deswegen
würde er euch in den Shownotes alle
popkulturellen Referenzen zu Harry
and Sally, Harry Mad Sally aufschreiben.
Und wir hatten ungefähr uns
verabredet und ich hatte noch anderthalb Stunden Zeit, dachte, wir holen
mir ein Sandwich und extrem viel los,
natürlich auch touristische Attraktionen. Wir waren verabredet, weil wir Karten
hatten für eine Show und
die fing sharp an, ne, also da war Punkt, Punkt fing die an. Und Katze-Delikatessen muss man sagen, da wird das dann immer so direkt zubereitet und geschnitten und es kann teilweise sehr lange dauern, es gibt lange Schlangen und ich war in der Schlange drin und es waren so fünf Leute vor mir und dann gibt es so verschiedene Stationen und ich war bei Station drei, dachte ich mir nicht zu früh, nicht zu spät, kann man gut hin. Wie Station drei?
Es gibt so acht verschiedene Stationen, wo du hingehen kannst und dann wird ein Sandwich gemacht und dann kriegt er das. Take away. Und man kann es dann auch an den Tisch nehmen, kein Problem. Oder Take away, aber ich war für Take away. Und dann stand ich da, da waren drei Leute vor mir, da hab ich eine Stunde gewartet, waren immer noch drei Leute vor mir. Und dachte dachte ich mir, das ist, also meine Dreisatzfähigkeiten geraten hier so ein bisschen ins Trudeln. Wir sind bei null Prozent Fortschritt. Wenn in einer Stunde null Leute bedient werden, wie lange dauert es bis dann drei bedient werden? Da habe ich so ein bisschen überlegt. Null. Du kannst nicht durch Null dividieren, das ist das Problem. Bevor ich jetzt hier mitten in New York anfange, durch Null zu dividieren, ich will jetzt hier also wirklich hier keinen grossen Aufruf machen. Mir bin ich gegangen, dachte ich, komm, hol ich mir noch schnell so eine Pizza auf die Hand, um schnell zu kommen. Wo gemerkt, diese Show, wo wir uns verabredet haben, alle wussten, dass es da Essen gibt. Ja, aber ich bin ja immer so ein YouTuber vor so einem Besuch. Ich mache dann so YouTube-Videos, die besten Restaurants und die besten Pizzen und so. Ich backe ja mittlerweile auch selber Pizza zu Hause und will mir so ein bisschen Inspiration geben. Und dann war ich da aber der Pizzerier und dann dachte ich mir, komm, holst du dir noch schön eine Pizza auf die Hand? Und dann, ich hasse solche Hipsterläden, die keine Speisekarte vorne dran haben, wo nicht steht, wie es läuft, wo einfach du das Gefühl hast, du gehst so eine Treppe runter in so ein dunkles Loch und dann wo irgendjemand so irgendwie von so einem Camus-Roman aufschaut. Ja, ja, und du gehst durch die Tür, klingelingelingelingelingeling. Und es so, was? Und ich so, I want food, please. Ja, hier gibt es die schon seit 2004 nicht mehr. Ja, welches? Can I see the menu? No, we don't have menus. The heart, your heart is the menu. Can I get a pizza? We don't have pizza, we don't have pizza. Okay, I'm going. We have empanadillas. What's an empanadilla? Never mind. Just go. Just leave. You're embarrassing. You're embarrassing. Sorry. You're worth nothing. Sorry. I'm sorry. Say you're sorry. Sorry, little pathetic guy. I'm a little pathetic guy. Say it. I'm a little pathetic guy. Say it. I'm a little pathetic guy. Can I use the restroom? We don't have restrooms. We never rest. We never rest. Resting is so boomer. And then came so a Kellnerin, and then it was like, wait here to be seated, and then
came a Kellnerin, where ich sagte, can I order for takeaway? Weil ich wollte die einfach schnell essen. Hey, excuse me, can I order for takeaway? Und dann auch, ja, Pizza, welche Pizza? Large oder small? Und ich kenne ja immer nur immer large, habe ich auch large und dann hat es ein bisschen gedauert und dann kam sie mit so einem grossen Zettel und meinte so, so, yeah, what's your name? Und Name ist immer für mich so blöd zu sagen, weil ich weiß dann immer nicht, was ich sagen soll. Soll ich sagen Florentin oder Florentine soll ich es irgendwie an, ist immer richtig unangenehm, weswegen ich den... Das ist gut mit Stefan, wo man einfach Stefan sagen kann. Stefan? Und dann kann ich denken, schreiben die es so wie wir. Und dann habe ich einen guten Ratschlag meines grossen Bruders genommen, der auch ab und zu international arbeitet und der sagt immer, ich sage einfach, ich heisse Will. Also ich nehme einfach den Nachnamen als Vornamen, ich sage einfach, ich bin Will. Super. Und dann habe ich auch gesagt Will. Und dann, okay, Will. Und dann meinte sie auch, last name?
Nein, oh nein. Und dann so wütend den Bruder angerufen.
Ja, ist ja ganz schön hier, aber dein dummer Tipp hat nicht funktioniert.
Was machst du denn, wenn sie dann deinen Nachnamen wissen wollen?
Und dann ist so, no, that's my last night. Und sie so, okay, what's your address? Why do you need my address? Und dann hat sie so ein komplettes Formular vor sich liegen. Und ich dachte schon, das läuft. Ah Mann, ich will doch nur ein Stück Pizza, warum ist das, warum gehe ich dann von einem Fettnäpfchen ins nächste? Du hast gesagt, ich möchte Take-away-Pizza. Und dann meinte ich so, weil sie hat in der so komplette Formular vor sich liegen, und ich meinte so, ist das für Delivery? Ja, Delivery. No, no, give it to me, just take it. I'm here, I'm standing right in front of you. Und sie meinte, you mean to go? Yeah, to go, aber take away. Anscheinend dachte diese Frau, ich komme persönlich in eine Pizzeria, um eine Pizza zu mir nach Hause zu bestellen, obwohl ich hier anwesend bin. Naja, zu Ihrer Verteidigung, sie wusste ja noch nicht, sie wusste ja noch nicht, wie viele Pizzen du bestellst. Kann sein, dass du für morgen zwölf Pizzen ins Büro XY bestellst, oder sowas. Ich dachte mir so, wie kann das denn so schief gehen? Und ich hab extra noch mal gegoogelt. Takeaway ist das vollkommen richtige Wort. Das war nicht mein Fehler. Aber ich denke mir, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Man merkt einfach so, aber das ist wahrscheinlich einfach so, wenn du nicht von da bist, dann kannst du nicht cool oder souverän wirken, weil du läufst immer in Bullshit rein. Egal wie gut du dich vorbereitest, egal wie gut du mit deiner Englischlehrerin nochmal sagst. Wir machen nach der Schuleproblem. Ich weiß nicht, was das Problem war. Ich habe irgendwas ausgestrahlt,
dass ich gerade nicht hungrig bin oder was auch immer.
Du hast ein Praktikantentum ausgestrahlt, glaube ich.
Du hast ausgestrahlt,
mein Boss hat mich hierher geschickt,
wir brauchen 25 Pizzen
und am besten
Pronto, aber ein bisschen Pronto.
Und
du hast dann wahrscheinlich zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo sie gesagt hat, what's the address? Wusstest du sie schon, dass es sich nur um eine Pizza handelt? Ja, wusste sie. Das verstehe ich ja nicht. Eine grosse Diabola. Aber vor allem dann dachte ich mir auch, Moment mal, Large Pizza kann halt auch wirklich gross heissen. Weil wer weiß, was das für Grössen sind. Ja, ja, gut. Family size, aber super unangenehm,
vor allem, ihr müsst euch vorstellen, so ein mega cooles Restaurant
mit so Kerzen und wirklich schöner Wanddekoration,
mit so Efeu und so wunderschön, wie so ein italienischer Keller.
Mittendrin steht schwitzig Florentin, denn ich weiß.
Schwitz mit meinem Rucksack, mit meinem Regenschirm,
mit meinem viel zu langen Regenschirm,
sitze ich da, da auf so einem Barhocker, viel zu gross, mit meinem Rucksack viel zu schwer, sitze ich da, wartend einfach, gucke jeden verängstigt an. Kennst du die Geräusche nicht, kennst du die Gerüche nicht. Am Ende habe ich viel zu spät und dann habe ich ja geguckt, weil ich hatte nicht mehr viel Zeit bis zu unserer Verabredung und dann dachte ich mir, fuck und dann meinte ich so, ja. Wo es Essen gibt. Dann kam er zu spät,
dann kam er zu spät,
wie sage ich mich das, er kam zu spät
mit einer grossen Pizza,
obwohl explizit verboten ist,
Outside Food mitzunehmen. Ich dürfte die Pizza
an einen Ort, wo es auch
Essen gibt, kam er
zu spät, weil er bei zwei
Essensstationen miserably
gefailt hat. Und dann habe ich die Pizza mit. Wie saß ich da? Mit einem schönen Wein. Mit einem Vino ganz entspannt. Ich hab nebenan entspannt einen Vino getrunken. Aber da war ich stolz, weil wir kamen zu spät, alles war stressig und du kamst lustig an mit so einem Riesenbox. Ich wusste ja von dieser ganzen Geschichte, dieser Kakophonie an Scheiss. Wusste ich ja noch nicht. Das heißt, plötzlich kam so Florian so rumgelaufen mit so einem Riesenpizzakarton, hat sich so umgeguckt und lief so mega nervös und dann so nebenbei, also ein Riesenpizzakarton, den er so balancieren musste. Large, offensichtlich war das die large Pizza. Nebenbei sein Handy, wo er die Adresse herausfindet, dann den Regenschirm noch in der Hand, irgendwie, zu dem Zeitpunkt es nicht mehr geregnet, und dann ist auch ein Regenschirm dusselig, so ein Anhängsel, und dann lief er dann so rum, so mega schnell und sein Gesicht hat gesagt, ah fuck, Stefan bringt mich um. Ja. Stefan hat ihn nicht umgebracht, Stefan hat gesagt, saß dann da plötzlich nebenan, neben der, wo die Show war, in so einer Weinbar, hat einen Wein getrunken und gesagt, komm, jetzt komm erst mal an, entspann dich. Ja, du warst wirklich der Gegenpol, du hast mich da wirklich runtergeholt. Ja, weil mein Plan für New York ist eigentlich Entspannung. Max Relax. Ich möchte hier Max Relax hinbringen. Die Stadt ist mir zu nervös, ich komme hier hin und sage, Leute, komm mal ein bisschen runter. Okay. Ach, du willst also die gesamte Stadt, du willst gar nicht die Stadt auf dich wirken lassen? Nein. willst einen Einfluss auf die Stadt haben. Ja. Okay. Interessanter Ansatz als Besucher für zehn Tage. Ja, und auch wahnsinnig narzisstisch und alles schlecht, aber ich möchte halt, aber gut. Das ist Folge 376, Stefan. Jetzt kann, ja genau, jetzt freue ich mich auch nicht mehr hinter dem Berg halten, dass ich hier so ein bisschen europäische Dolce Vita, Savo Vivre hinbringen möchte. Deswegen habe ich das auch überlegt, jetzt den Rucksack zu fallen zu lassen. Nein, Rucksack muss sein. Wo ist die Flasche? Wo ist die Wasserflasche? In der Hand. Ich habe die ganze Zeit, wenn man nämlich Paparazzi-Fotos sieht von Promis, so A-List-is, so Timothy Chalamet oder sowas, die laufen ohne Rucksack herum in ihren weirden Klamotten und haben immer eine kleine Wasserflasche in der Hand. Ja. Eine ganz kleine Wasserflasche. Das ist meine, das möchte ich machen. Damit sie größer wirken. Die Wasserflasche kann auch größer sein, wie die, die ich jetzt in der Hand habe hier, so ein Litter-Whatever-Ding. Aber ich würde gerne
so rumlaufen.
Einfach kein Rucksack,
entspannt. Du hast auch, mit dem Rucksack
hast du ein anderes Tempo. Du läufst direkt
so Walking-Style.
Also es ist wirklich so ein bisschen schneller.
Es ist quasi Wandern. Es ist ein bisschen Wandern, genau.
Ich bringe das genaue Gegenteil, ich habe immer alles dabei.
Ich habe aktuell dabei mein Laptop,
meine Festplatte, mein Ladegerät, habe ich immer dabei, wenn ich unterwegs bin. Alle Schlüssel, auch für mich zu Hause, eine Wasserflasche, eine Küchenrolle, Taschentücher, Kindle, Powerbank, Ladekabel für alles, was ich habe, Kopfhörer, Handy, Taschentücher, nochmal vorne, eine Feile, Nagelklipser habe ich immer dabei, immer, Deo, Feuchtigkeitscreme, alles immer dabei. Ich bin immer gerüstet für alles. Jetzt gerade habe ich auch viel dabei, weil wir ja auch gerade den Podcast aufnehmen. Sonst, wenn ich in New York rumlaufe, Kopfhörer, Portemonnaie, Handy, that's it. Ja, das ist schon nicht schlecht. Ich meine, wir sind erst zwei Tage hier, ich habe es noch nicht gemacht. Und ich habe jetzt schon ehrlich gesagt Angst davor. Ich stelle mir dich vor wie so eine Schildkröte, die eines Tages sagt, weißt du was, heute bin ich mal locker unterwegs. Und dann schlüpft die so aus ihrem Panzer raus. Und in dem Moment kommt so eine High-Heals-Frau. Direkt der Adler. Aber davor hatte der so ein kurzes Gefühl so, ey, das ist in Ordnung. Erleuchtung. Das ist eigentlich in Ordnung, so muss es sein. Aber ich hab dann, es war tatsächlich anstrengend, weil ich durfte die Pizza dann nicht essen während der Show, hatte sie aber einfach als Gepäck dabei. Und das ist ja eigentlich, fand ich ganz interessant, weil... Du hast sie mir gegeben für den Check-In. Ist ja eigentlich interessant, weil normalerweise ist es ja so, so eine Pizza ist ja ein Kunstwerk, also da wirkt ja wirklich die jahrhundertelange Kunst in der gesamten Kultur, fließt die hinein, und Mehl, und dann musst du das alles gären lassen, und Hefe und so. Ja, drei Zutaten. Normalerweise kriegst du die Pizza. Ist das nicht das einfache Gericht? Na, aber das ist schon viel, du musst das auch richtig gehen lassen, und dann musst du dann auch genau zur richtigen Zeit backen, so. Und dann denke ich mir so, normalerweise kriegt man die Pizza und isst sie sofort, was eigentlich eine Verschwendung
ist. Aber ich hatte diese Pizza wirklich als
meinen Weggefährte dabei und
dann saß ich in dieser Show und die Pizza war wirklich
wie bei so einem Date gegenüber auf dem
anderen Stuhl, lag die Pizza in ihrem
Pizzakarton. Ich durfte sie nicht essen und das hat
es echt nochmal interessant gemacht, weil
man hat so Vorfreude, es reift so nach
und du denkst, oh gleich esse ich sie und so und am Ende
war sie leider so scharf. Das was? Das sehr scharf war. Ja. Sehr scharf. Die war wirklich scharf. Weil du es gesagt hast mit dem Regenschirm. Gestern hat es geregnet und wir hatten beide einen Regenschirm. Und ich bin ja immer auf der Suche nach einem USP, ich hatte immer Bowlingschuhe. Ich fand es auch geil, den in den Hand zu haben. Dann hatte ich den Chubber Chubs im Geldbeutel. Und irgendwie hatte ich gestern richtig Spaß damit, mit so einem Gehstock-Regenschirm rumzulaufen. Hast du ihn als Gehstock benutzt? Ich habe ihn irgendwann als Gehstock benutzt. Ich habe ihn in der Mitte angefasst. Und wie so ein... Wie so ein Baguette. Wie so ein Doppel-Lightsaber. Wie so ein Darth Maul-Artikel. Mit beiden Hinden. Nee, eine Hand, aber... Und dann wurde ich aber im Museum ermahnt. Oh, weil du zu viel rumgefuchtelt hast.
Nee, nicht wegen des Rumfuchtelns, sondern wegen der Möglichkeit von potenziellen Ungeschicken.
Dass du da schön in Monet erdeuchst oder was, weil du eifersüchtig bist, dass du so gut malen kannst.
In den Raum bin ich gegangen und habe gesagt, ach, dann bin ich weggegangen.
Diese scheisse Seerosen. Lass mich mit den Seerosen alleine.
Monet ist doch super.
Lass mich mit den Seerosen alleine, Monet.
Ja, aber die sind doch schön. Habe ich schon zu oft gesehen. Die sind doch schön. Hier, Seerosen. Ach, brauche ich nicht. Sind die schön. Und die hier. Guck mal, die hier. Oder die. Und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, man hat mit Monet so einen Abend verbracht und dann ist man mit seiner Frau dann so nach Hause gefahren und beide haben gelästert, dass er schon wieder nur über diese Seerosen gesprochen hat. Genau, er stelle ich die Seerosenines Thema. Aber Schatz, da sprichst du auch Seerosen an, du weisst doch, dass es das Thema ist, wo er den ganzen Abend nicht aufhört. Oh Gott. Die einzige Chance, die wir haben, ist es einfach nicht zu erwähnen. Immerhin besser als bei Edward Munch zu Hause. Ja. Ja, das stimmt. Aber irgendwie hat mir das gefallen. Ich sage jetzt nicht, dass ich jetzt einen Gehstock habe als pfiffiges, exzentrisches Accessoire. Oder mit so einer Dämonenkralle, wenn man dann so greift, wie Lucius Malfoy. Lucius Malfoy. Der den Zauberstab, Achtung Spoiler, der den Zauberstab in dem Gehstock drin hatte. Finde ich albern. Wo der dann immer diesen Knubbel vorne dran hatte, wo ich mir auch dachte, das ist super ungünstig. Wo tragen die eigentlich immer ihren Zwei? In der Robe. Ich habe ja eine Robe mal gehabt für eine Themenparty, Harry Potter, habe ich mich eingedeckt. Ja, das wissen wir alle. Und da hatte ich dann auch diese Robe und in der Robe ist so eine Aussparung, so eine Tasche, so eine längliche Tasche, so ein, ja, für Halfter. Für eine Schwertscheide. Ja, es ist eingewoben in den Umhang und da konnte man es reinzuhören, das macht natürlich am meisten Spaß. Ich glaube, wenn ich ein Ritter wäre, weil am meisten Spaß macht Schwert rausziehen und dann so, na gut, dann haben wir uns nochmal verstanden, wieder reinzustecken. Und ich glaube, ich würde ständig versuchen, Anlässe zu finden, um den rauszuziehendes Schwert. Weil so, allerdings kommt der Ritter nach Hause, Schatz, ich habe heute kein einziges Mal mein Schwert rausgezogen. Hey, hm, Hermann, hm? Als ich zum Ritter geschlagen wurde, dachte ich, ich könnte viel häufiger mein Schwert ziehen und dann so sch...
Wir haben Zeiten des Friedens.
Ja, ich weiss, das ist ja auch gut, aber ich meine, ich poliere das Schwert jeden Tag.
Ich weiss, es ist wunderschön poliert.
Es ist wirklich... Ich kann damit auch echt gut umgehen und gar nicht jetzt irgendwie kämpfen, sondern auch wie es heilte dann verbringen wir jetzt halt mit deinen Kindern zum Beispiel, mit dem Friedrich und der Kleine. Hm? Wie, nee? Nee, ich meine, mein großer Traum, Ritter zu sein. Guck mal, heute Abend hier gibt es dieses grosse Leibbrot. Das kannst du doch schneiden. Wirklich? Das kannst du doch schneiden. Guck mal, das ist ein großes Leibbrot.
Ja, hat jemand Hunger?
Ja, wir haben alle Hunger.
Okay.
Guck mal, Papa macht... Oh, das ist aber angstentflössend.
Hui, guck mal, der kleine Friedrich...
Oh, ist das ein großes Stück?
Ist das ein großes Stück?
Okay, danke.
Na dann, er hat nochmal Glück gehabt.
Und willst du auch die Butter draufstreichen?
Oh Gott, was war denn? Lame, lame guy.
Aber will man einfach.
Ja, man will es schon.
Das ist einfach ein gutes Gefühl.
Mir reicht schon der Regenschirm-Moment.
Aber Regenschirm aufmachen?
Ja, der ist auch geil.
Wobei beim Regenschirm ist das Zumachen tricky. Da wirklich souverän und cool auszusehen, ist sehr schwer, weil du musst dann so weg und dann so schütteln und so hin und her und ab wann kann man dann die ganze Zeit den Regen kontrollieren, ist immer so ein bisschen schwer. Genau, also es ist immer ein bisschen schwer, aber ich mag das sehr, dieses Aufmachen und Zumachen ins Regenschirm. Und da muss ich auch sagen, klar, heutzutage alle, Knirps, Knirps, Knirps, der grosse Hype, ich kenn's ja. Was? Aber ich finde den klassischen alten... Bin ich in einem Paralleluniversum? Knirps? Ne, den kleinen, einfahrbaren Regenschirm, den man in die Tasche stecken kann. Wer heißt Knirps? Knirps, ja.
Wann habt ihr euch alle entschlossen, den so zu nennen?
Da war ein Meeting, wir sassen alle zusammen.
Ich dachte, du warst dabei.
Es ist wie damals, als alle Pampers gesagt haben zu windeln.
Habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Und Tempo zu Taschentüchern.
Was ist los?
Nee, wir waren alle da.
Wir waren alle da und haben abgestimmt.
Alle?
Warst du nicht dabei?
Der Saal war so gross. Der Saal war so gross. Wann war das dachte, wir haben alle abgestimmt, ob wir es nennen sollen. Wann? Das war im Mai. Das war im Mai irgendwann und dann gab es die grosse Abstimmung, wie sollen kleine Regenschirme heißen? Zu einem Mail bekommen oder was? Ja, und dann war die Frage, heisst es Knirps oder Regenschirmchen? Dann haben wir über, es war sehr knapp, es war sehr knapp tatsächlich. Wenn ich mich sogar recht entscheide, erinnere,
hatte Knirps sogar nur
eine Stimme mehr als Regenschirmchen.
Und wenn ich da gewesen wäre, hätte ich...
Moment mal, heißt es, wenn du dabei gewesen wärst?
Wäre unentschieden. Hättest du das
Schicksal nochmal abwenden können? Ja!
Ja, Stefan, du musstest solche
Sachen auch hingehen. Ich krieg
in dieser Newsletter-Mail-Liste nicht drin, für wie wir Dinge nennen. Waren alle da, wirklich alle waren da. Wer? Adam, Bettina, Christian, Deborah. Erik auch? Erik war da. Aber nicht Finn. Fiona war da. Fiona und Finn? Gerhard, Hilde, alle waren da. Ina? Ina war am Anfang da, aber die musste dann weg. Aber Jan war nicht da. Dann per Briefwahl. Aber Jan war nicht da. Jan war nicht da. Carsten? Oh ja, Carsten war da. Der hat einen grossen Aufstand gemacht, der war riesen Fan von Regenschirmchen, aber... Luis hat wahrscheinlich dann... Luis war für Knirps. Das ist ein Knirps-Guy. Aber was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, der Knirps hat natürlich seine Vorteile. Wieso bist du eh gekommen? Ich hätte das jetzt durchgezogen. Bis Ö. Ömer. Bis Ä... Ägidie. Der Knirps macht Spaß und hat Vorteile, aber so ein schöner, langer, sperriger Regenschirm, das ist was Feines. Das hat mir richtig Spaß gemacht damit durch die Gegend. Fallisch. Ja, klar, fallisch, schwertisch, waffisch, hat alles was. Nee, nee, Schwerter sind auch fallisch. Du kannst nicht so was Fallischem Schwertisch sagen. Ja, na gut, aber das ist natürlich übersetzt sich ja. Ja, ja, übersetzt sich.
Letzten Endes ist alles
natürlich fallisch. Ich meine, Mikrofon...
Glück gestern, dass wir
beide Regenschirme
in der Wohnung hatten.
Ja, das stimmt. Da muss man echt sagen,
hätten wir nur einen Regenschirm gehackt, wir beide,
dann hätten wir gesagt, komm Stefan, dann gehen wir doch zusammen.
Dann hätten wir uns zusammen gekuschelt.
Naja, du bist riesengroß und dann hättest du immer den Regenschirm im Gesicht gehabt, weil ich so klein bin. Und gut, dass wir zwei hatten auf jeden Fall. Voll stark, ja. Aber ich weiß nicht, ab welchem Alter man guten Gehstock benutzen kann. Also ob es eine Altersstufe gibt, ob ich überhaupt reingelassen werde in so einen Gehstockladen oder so, oder ab wann man da gut reinkommt. Ich verstehe viele Sachen nicht, also wie das entsteht, wahrscheinlich durch eine Krankheit, so Doktorhausartige Humpelgeschichte. Wahrscheinlich, ja, ja. So entstehen, glaube ich, Gehstock, ich glaube, es ist fast Appropriation, wenn du einfach jetzt anfängst, einen Gehstock zu nehmen, als dein Ding, aber das will ich jetzt nicht, will ich jetzt nicht beschwören, aber ich finde es so lustig, Menschen, irgendwann fangen Menschen einen Hut zu tragen. Ja. Oder so eine Schirmmütze. Aber was ist denn mit so einem Hirtenstock? Mit so einem langen Hirtenstock, der auch so ... Weil was ich am Regenschirm auch mag, ist diese Krümmung, dieser Haken, dieser Griff. Den finde ich natürlich auch gut, weil ich mir immer denke, wie würde ich kämpfen? Ne, mit dem Regenschirm. Mit dem Griff nach oben, mit der Spitze nach vorne. Man kann Dinge klauen mit dem Regenschirm. Kann er mit richtig gutem machen. Gibt es doch auch ein paar Filmszenen, wo jemand so I'm singing in the rain. Niemand weiss nicht, wo der geht. Was macht er auch sonst? Wo dann auch so ein Extrablatt, Extrablatt Junge ist und der sagt, jetzt komm mal her. Dann packt er dem so am Nacken und zieht den so ran. Dann sagt er, my paper's getting wet. My paper's getting wet. Is it don't you like the rain? Oh, it's paper's getting wet. Hast du den Film nicht gesehen? Nein. Welchen Film? Ich hab auch einen Singing in the Rain. Nee, hab ich nicht gesehen. Ich hab gerade nur gedacht, was für ein lamer Text.
Ey, wir brauchen noch Sir.
Ja.
Sir.
Wir brauchen noch den Song für diese Stelle, wo der Typ im Regen singt.
Ach, wo er im Regen singt, ne?
Ja.
Sir.
Pass auf.
Aus der Ich-Perspektive?
Es klingt so ein bisschen nach seiner ersten Idee, also kann er gerne ein bisschen origineller sein. Das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist einden uns dann drei Jahre später. Ist der Text fertig geworden? Der Text ist fertig. Ich habe mir überlegt, was könnte ein Mensch sagen, der im Regen singt? Was geht in ihm vor? Ich habe ja gesagt, das kann sehr offen, sehr abstrakt sein und so. Versucht, ihn hineinzuversetzen. Genau. Passen Sie auf. I am singing in the rain. Genau, aber was singt er dann? I am, das ist der Text. I am singing in the rain. Das macht ja überhaupt keinen Sinn. Achtung, zweite Zeile, just singing in the rain. Das untergräbt ja alles andere, was er auch macht. Er singt, was er tut. Aber er tanzt ja währenddessen auch. Er tut, was er singt. Er singt seine tiefsten emotionalen Vorgänge, singt er frei heraus. I am singing in the rain right now. Rain is dribbling on my face. Haben Sie die Deadline vergessen einfach? Äh, ja, ich habe nicht mehr damit gerechnet, dass Sie nach drei Jahren tatsächlich noch auf meine Villa in Teneriffa kommen. Nee, ich habe mich einkündigt vor drei Jahren. Ach, sie, ja. Aber ich finde, irgendwas stört mich am Singing in the Rain sehr. Weil normalerweise Dinge, also irgendwie, ich versuche es mal zu beschreiben, aber irgendwas stöße mich daran. Weil wenn Leute etwas singen, ist da irgendwie so eine Suspension of disbelief, dass sie das nicht wirklich singen, sondern sagen. Weißt du, was ich meine? Okay, ja. Und wenn man singt, I'm singing in the rain. Ach so, du meinst, dass er zugibt, dass er singt. Ja. Undgegen normale Musical-Darsteller singen ja in der Welt nicht, sondern reden. Genau. Oder drücken ihre Emotionen aus. Die fangen nicht plötzlich an zu singen und alle sagen, was aus Maria uns jetzt zu sagen.
Also bei Hamilton sagt jemand nicht, Mr. Hamilton, warum singen sie?
Okay, I'm singing, okay.
Aber was würdest du sagen, I'm dancing in the rain.
Zum Beispiel, I'm dancing in the rain, I'm speaking normally, I'm talking in a normal, moderate voice during rainfall.
During what happens to be rainfall over New York City. During the apparently happening weather situation. Ja, enlightenment of clouds. Yes. Cloudy, sowas halt. Wir sind durch die Wolken geflogen. Wann? Im Flugzeug. Ja. Das war abgefahren. Ich muss zugeben, ich habe immer Angst im Flugzeug. Bin ich ehrlich? Immer Angst im Flugzeug? Ich habe Angst, dass wir abstürzen. Idiot. Ja, muss ich einfach sagen, ich meine, es ist einfach so ein offensichtlich gefährliches Verkehrsmittel. Es ist nicht faktisch gefährlich, aber du schaust raus und denkst dir, wow, wow sind wir hoch, richtig hoch. So geil. Schwerkraft. Ich habe, glaube ich, dreimal die Stewardess genervt und meinte,
gib mir noch.
Sorry, sorry.
Want another drink?
Sind Sie sich im Klaren, dass es Schwerkraft gibt?
Also, dass die Erde uns anzieht?
Ja, na klar.
Okay, alles klar, sorry, ich wollte nur, Entschuldigung,
ich wollte nur sicher gehen, dass das,
weil eigentlich würde uns die Schwerkraft ja nach unten ziehen, weil wir Ja, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, ich wollte nur, Entschuldigung, ich wollte nur sicher gehen, dass das, weil eigentlich würde uns die Schwerkraft ja nach unten ziehen, weil wir so weit oben sehen, würde es sein.
Der Kapital ist unsere Kontrolle.
Ah, okay, wunderbar, ich wollte einfach nur, nicht dass es jetzt irgendwie so ein Ding ist, was dann alle vergessen und, was ist das? Was schenken Sie mir da ein?
Cremont.
Oh, bien sûr. Sie sind doch so jung, warum können Sie sich die erste Klasse leisten? Wissen Sie, ich schreibe Texte für Musicals. Das ist Shirt von Clark an. Das und ich schreibe Texte für Musicals. Oh, vielleicht kennen Sie sogar einen meiner Songs. Und Ihre Choro-Kappe. Ja, das auch, aber ich schreibe nebenbei. Vielleicht kennen Sie einen meiner Songs. I'm singing on the stage. Oh mein Gott. You are listening to me singing. Sie, Sie. Was? Sie sind einer dieser Abstraktionisten. Ich bin Abstraktionistin. Ja, Sie mögen es abstrakt, ich weiss es, ich sehe es Ihnen genau an. Das wird zu wenig poetisch. Sachlich. Ich finde es total toll, Ich liebe auch Turbulenzen. Ich liebe, liebe, liebe Turbulenzen. Du liebst Turbulenzen. Ich liebe Turbulenzen. Als einziger Mensch der Welt. Nein, das stimmt nicht. Also alle Panik und Schreck. Das stimmt nicht. Und nur du. Ich finde es mega geil. Es ist etwas irgendwie Kindliches, wie man wird so gewiegt von dem Flugzeug, in den Schlaf gewiegt. Ich finde es total geil, es hat was Achterbahnartiges,
dass dann der Magen plötzlich noch
irgendwie zwei Stockwerke oben ist
oder so. Ich finde es geil, es hat was
wild, es passiert was,
der Kapitän meldet sich, erzählt etwas
über den
Biskaya-Tief
oder so,
erzählt uns wettertechnische Sachen, wenn man Glück hat,
wenn man Glück hat, und dann ist es immer so spannend, muss man die Sachen festhalten oder kommt. Ja, ja, ja. Es ist cool, es passiert ein bisschen was. Ja, es ist, aber ich glaube, ich habe dieses, mit diesem Flug, ich fliege ja nicht so oft wirklich, jetzt echt mal Wolken gecheckt, glaube ich. Ich habe das nicht gecheckt. Für mich war immer die Frage, es regnet jetzt schon seit zwei Stunden. Wo
zur Hölle haben die
Wolken all das Wasser her?
Und jetzt glaube ich, habe ich es gecheckt.
Weil Wolken sind
fucking dick
und hoch. Also wenn du
von unten nach oben guckst, denkst du dir,
ah, das ist eine Wolkenschicht. Aber die
Wolken selber sind ja... Die Flache, zwei Zentimeter
Wolken. Genau, die Wolken sind ja kilometerhohe Wolkentürme also das ist ja dann so ein paar Kilometer Abstand und dann nochmal viel, viel mehr Wolkentürme und das habe ich jetzt mal wirklich gesehen von oben und jetzt denke ich mir bei Regen, nee, das hat schon seinen Sinn, das passt schon Vulkane, äh bin ich immer noch so ein bisschen hinterhergerissen. Aber ist okay, eins nach dem anderen. Wenn du jetzt Regen verstanden hast, ist das doch schon mal schön. Nein, aber Regen, denke ich mir, mittlerweile ist, aber ich, check ich. Super. Verstehe ich, weil das sind einfach riesige Türme und der Regentropfen fliegt ja auch erstmal durch die ganzen Wolken durch. Du hast ja die Wolke, das ist immer die Wolke und dann kommt unten der Regen raus. Aber über der Wolke ist ja noch eine Wolke und noch eine Wolke und noch eine Wolke und noch eine Wolke, das ist ja riesig und es fällt ja erstmal durch die andere Wolke durch. Ja, aber der kommt ja vielleicht gar nicht von unten. Ich glaube, der akkumuliert sich, bin ich ehrlich. Der fliegt ja vielleicht erstmal durch ganz andere Gegenden so. Der fängt irgendwo an bei sich in der Heimat Tschüssüss, Mami. Tschüss. Halt so einen Rucksack auf.
Dankeschön.
Tschüss. Wir sind so stolz auf dich.
Tschüss, bis heute Abend.
Trophi, wir sind so stolz auf dich. Macht's gut, bis heute Abend.
Macht's gut.
Und dann kommt es durch eine andere Gegend.
Und dann irgendwie so.
Und wirklich ewig lang. Und erst dann freier Fall.
Ja.
Splash! Und dann so der Scheibenwischer. Das Leben einer, das Ringtropfen finde ich aber auch ganz spannend. Ja, gibt eine tolle Werbung. Äh, Edeka-Spot, Edeka-Weihnachtspot. Tropfen. Wirklich? Wolkenstadt. Und dann so ein Tropfen auf dem heißen Stein. Edeka. Nee, die Werbung ist von einem Kumpel von mir tatsächlich, der hat die geschrieben. Wirklich? Ja, der Weihnachtsbott von vor zwei Jahren oder sowas. Also die Tropfen machen sich bereit und freuen sich darauf, einzigartige Schneeflocken zu werden. Und freuen sich an und proben dafür und so und lernen, haben Unterricht und alles ist so pixermässig, super süss und so kleine Tropfen mit riesen Augen und freuen sich, endlich Regentropfen, äh, Schnee zu werden. Und dann plötzlich gibt es einen Schneealarm, einen grossen Alarm und der Tropfen ist ganz aufgeregt und freut sich und springt runter, aber er wird nicht zu einer Schneeflocke, wie er gelernt hat und wie es sein soll. Und er wird nicht und es kommt, die Erde kommt immer näher, aber er wird nicht zur Schneeflocke. Und dann klatscht er gegen so eine Scheibe und da steht so ein kleines Mädchen. Und da ist Weihnachten feiern die offensichtlich und sie guckt in die Scheibe und es fängt an zu regnen. Und dann Edeka, damit es bald wieder weisse Weihnachten gibt. Wir achten auf Nachhaltigkeit. Hui, okay. Ja, aber Regentropfen sind alle gleich. Ich kann so laut klatschen, es ist so cool.
Du kannst wahnsinnig laut klatschen, ja.
Das ist ein cooles Spiel, den ich habe.
Ja, ja. Kannst du? Wow, okay.
Ja, geil, jetzt nochmal am Ende der Folge, wo alle eingeschlafen sind, klatscht die nochmal wach.
Kannst du deine Technik erklären? Hast du dir das selber beigebracht?
Oder ist das einfach... Organisch.
Starke Hände.
Nee, nee, ich glaube, also die Technik ist, ä ist, naja, fühlt euren Knochen zwischen, im Handballen rede ich schon, also in Innenfläche, da habt ihr Knochen vom Zeigefinger und Mittelfinger, die da oben sind. Also gegenüber den Knöcheln. Gegenüber der Knöchel. Ja. Genau, die Handinnenfläche, die Knochen, die erfüllt ihr und in die Mitte legt ihr den Ringfinger der anderen Hand. Und die anderen ergeben sich dann automatisch. Zwischen die Knochen von Mittel- und Zeigefinger, den rechten Ringfinger. Mittelfinger. Mittelfinger. So, das ist ungefähr die Position, die ihr wollt, dieses. Da habt ihr so richtig schön, deckt ihr alles ab. Aha, also das ist asymmetrisch, das ist gar nicht klatschgleich. Das ist so albern, das ist das Comic-Klatschen.
Okay, alles klar, gut.
Ja, vielen Dank für diesen kleinen technischen Hinweis.
Können wir, glaube ich, häufiger mal machen in der Folge, oder?
Können wir gerne machen. Einfach mal so einen kleinen technischen Hinweis.
Aber bitte immer, immer klatschen.
Ich glaube, irgendwann, das kann ja deine Masterclass sein.
Stefan Tietze Masterclass, okay,ing, schreiben. Meet your new master. Mein Name ist Stefan Tietze und das ist meine Masterclass. Clapping, 18 Lektionen. 18 Sekunden. Vielen Dank, Flo und Hinten, fürs Erscheinen. Vielen Dank an euch da draußen fürs Zuhören.
Das war die kleine New York-Folge.
Es geht ganz normal weiter.
Macht euch da keine Gedanken.
Es bleibt jetzt nicht so.
Wir bleiben nicht hier.
Und wünschen euch natürlich viel Spaß.
Haut rein, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Wünschen euch eine ganz tolle Woche.
Und wir sagen, wir heben am Mars New York ab. Das ist eine Worst Bird Produktion.